So let's think about risks in managing partners.
Well, the biggest one is what I call impedance mismatch,
and again I've been talking about this a couple of times in this lecture.
In a startup, you barely register on a large company's radar.
In fact, you're entire company's staff is probably less than the administrative staff
of the CEOs of some of these companies,
and the longest of the partners schedules become your longest item, and what does that mean?
I've seen many types, large companies say, well,
we'll make that decision when we get to our plan and meeting
and any less, but when is the plan and meeting?
Oh we have that quarterly.
Well quarterly 90 days to startup is like we make decisions in an hour and a half.
And so now all of a sudden, the longest of their meeting
and decision schedules becomes your longest item and if you're working like startups should
on an intense speed and tempo, they are now slowing you down.
The third thing is when you're using strategic alliances or joint ventures,
there is no clear ownership of the customer, and in fact, if there is any owner
at all the large companies will say, oh you know, we have a thousand people in the field.
Don't worry. We'll take care of this.
But when you typically never realizes, your product to those thousand people in the field,
might put a little asterisk on page 49 of their sells price list and again when you do joint ventures,
that will make you sure who owns the vision because products by committee
are probably the worse thing that could happen to a star-up and your objectives tend to differ.
You need to understand what happens in a large company when you become part of the partnership.
Were you there as a check list item that someone said, oh we need one of this in our catalog?
Were you there for someone to career to look with or you absolutely essential for their success?
Don't confuse big name company being interested in you with a potential liquidity event.
Most of these partnerships fail, and one that isn't intuitively obvious is that a great person
who you are dealing with in that large company--
the odds are in 15 months, they're no longer in that job.
Because if their career is heading in the right direction,
they're going to be promoted or moved to another job or another division or another location,
and therefore, the person who is passionate about your relationship is now gone.
So if there is no underlying rationale. If there's no real what's in it for them?
The turn in partners and strategies or personnel might put your company out of business
and then never notice the difference.
You were just a short-term play for whoever was in the job
and if this was an important to their company though it might have been essential to yours,
that deal is over even though you might have a contract.
The other thing startups worry about is intellectual property issues
typically not much of an issue in the United States, typically a very, very, very--
more very's inserted to your important issue in dealing with China.
Intellectual property and the rule of laws or trait, and trademarks, and IP
is not quite the same in the US as it is in China, Russia, India and other developing nations.
You should make sure that you're not dealing with IP issues in these countries as you would in the US.
Finally, these deals are difficult to unwind or end.
This might've looked like a great idea when you were struggling startup.
Eighteen months later, when you're revenues rolling in, you realized that you gave these large companies
or these joint ventures or the strategic partners resources or assets or other things,
you never would've done two years later, and so we really think through,
what happens 2 years from now?